okay so the topic of this short video
today is going to be the three different
types of rna mrna trna rrna so let's go
ahead and get started
okay so let's talk about ribonucleic
acid when you look at the picture rna on
the right you can see it's only a single
strand of nucleotides but the picture of
dna on the left dna is a double helix
because it's made from two strands of
nucleotides
well rna is still a nucleic acid so it's
still made from building blocks called
nucleotides and nucleotides have three
parts one being a phosphate a second
being sugar a sugar molecule now the
picture that just showed up this is the
sugar called ribose this is the sugar of
rna
on the left this is the sugar called
deoxyribose this is the sugar of dna
they're virtually identical highlighted
in red is the difference the sugar on
the left deoxyribose it's been deoxied
it's missing an oxygen atom other than
that they're they're very similar to one
another
and then the the third part of a
nucleotide is the nitrogen base in rna
the nitrogen base might be a for adenine
it might be g for guanine it might be c
for cytosine and it might be u for
uracil these are the four nucleotide
nitrogen bases
of rna
and ultimately we're going to learn
about the three kinds of rna we're going
to learn about mrna and then we'll learn
about trna and then we'll learn about
our rna so let's talk about mrna first
okay so the m of mrna stands for
messenger messenger rna and you're going
to see it's going to start in the
nucleus of a cell but it will end up at
a ribosome well here's a cell right here
and let's talk about eukaryotic cells
first eukaryotic cells have a nucleus
and in that nucleus is the dna of the
cell now you might know that dna is the
instructions or the blueprint to build
all the proteins that we need
but the actual maker of the protein is a
ribosome a ribosome is the actual
builder of the protein and that's out in
the cytoplasm
so what does mrna do it makes a copy of
the dna code it makes a copy of the dna
sequence it makes a copy of the dna
instructions
and messenger rna will deliver the
instructions from the nucleus
to the ribosome and once the ribosome
has the instructions what the ribosome
will do is we'll build a protein and it
does that by gathering up a bunch a
bunch a bunch of amino acids and linking
them in a long chain which eventually is
protein and this is a process called
translation we're going to learn more
about translation in another video but
that's what a ribosome will eventually
do is gather the amino acids and link
them into a protein
okay now for transfer rna the
uh the t stands for transfer transfer
rna and the location is going to be in
the cytoplasm now in my cell drawing
here
i remove the nucleus from the drawing
just to get rid of some of the clutter
in the drawing
but this is also in eukaryotic cells and
what happens is
we said a moment ago the ribosome is
going to gather amino acids to make a
protein but how how does the ribosome
actually obtain the amino acids well
transfer rna will pick them up and carry
the amino acids over to the ribosome so
when a ribosome is making a protein
it needs the help of transfer rna
transfer rna is actually picking up the
amino acids and carrying them and
delivering them to the ribosome and one
by one one by one the amino acids are
picked up by transfer rna delivered to
the ribosome and so you see what's
happening now is the ribosomes are
linking the amino acids together one by
one by one in order to make a protein
this is again the process called
translation i have another video that
discusses translation if you're looking
to explore this in more detail but
that's the general job of transfer rna
and then the final kind of rna is r or
ribosomal our rna
and so the
the the rrna is the main component of a
rib is a ribosome is a cell part that
makes proteins but ribosomes are made
from something and uh our rrna
will bond with some special proteins in
the cell to form a ribosome so a
ribosome is actually made from
twisted uh twisted together our rna and
proteins and then a ribosome when it's
you know when it's constructed uh it
will help to build a protein through the
process called translation
so there you go a quick little video on
the basics of rna and some of the types
of rna and so here's a little practice
quiz for you to try hope you find this
helpful thanks for watching